[Music]
[Applause]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was i've heard it so
much i now answer to
henry winkler wrote the fonz
matt leblanc
wrote joey
steven tyler wrote
hey lady
[Applause]
see what we're doing now all right
people often don't recognize me when tom
selleck wrote i shaved my mustache
noah wiley wrote i'm wearing my glasses
snooki wrote i shave my mustache
all answered this is amazing
divorce is heidi klum wrote awful
jennifer lopez wrote hurtful
newt gingrich wrote annual
[Applause]
if i were a car i'd be ellie kemper
wrote a mini cooper
rosario dawson wrote a bmw
lindsay lohan wrote crashing into an
appliance store
i hope the next president of the united
states will be
bill clinton wrote honest
george w bush wrote dignified
barack obama wrote black
the historical figure at most three
presidents replied i know
it's unbelievable
that they would take the time to do that
for us for us flattering incredible
the historical figure i'd most like to
have dinner with is patton oswald wrote
abraham lincoln
hugh laurie wrote jesus christ
gary busey wrote that monkey from
friends
um
[Music]
i'm with gary on that one yeah yeah
monkey was fun i was named after joel
mchale wrote my grandfather
julie bowen wrote my mom's sister
jay-z and beyonce's baby blue ivy wrote
a paint chip at sherwin-williams
every once in a while i will eat mitt
romney wrote too much steak
ron paul wrote a giant bowl of ice cream
chris christie wrote tents with campers
still in them
and finally
i think the dark knight rises will be
elijah wood wrote the best batman movie
yet
charlie day wrote a great end to the
series
herman cain wrote a good slang term for
my next erection
i believe herman cain wrote that no